[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh and
we thought we would kick it off uh with
a few questions for lana about
tracing the trajectory of the book where
it comes from and how her thinking has
evolved
um that's all right should we get
started lana sure yeah i mean the other
thing just by way of introduction
um i wanted to say was um you know when
aston
and i talked about this we were
initially imagining
it just the as we understood it as kind
of a closed
um group conversation with cms students
um which i'm totally excited for it to
for
all kinds of people uh who some of whom
i know some of whom i don't to be here
um but we do because we you know we're
both
alumni of cms we do want to make sure
that our kind of initial and primary
audience are the graduate students so
we're going to kind of have that lens in
mind and we want to also
um be sure to answer questions
and talk both about the book but also
about the trajectories of both of our
careers
as to cms folks from
two different eras really and different
eras from
the present uh who have made academic
careers um
and are now in the same department uh
somewhat you know quite fortuitously
um so yeah so in addition to the book i
i do want this to take this opportunity
to
have a kind of broader conversation um
one of the reasons why
i asked you know aspen to be my
interlocutor on this is
that um you know we are colleagues now
and i
really respect his work and i think he
will uh will
will bring kind of an interesting other
flip side to the conversation
but also you know when i was a cms
student we got the word
that that aswan had just gotten a
tenure-track job
and he was the first cms alum as far as
we i knew
um to get the 10-year trek job and as
part of our
process in selecting um you know working
up to the
thesis you know we were asked to read um
papers
and read prior theses from previous cms
students and and
i one of the ones that i read was aswin
so i was always
i've been a big fan of aspen since
before he had a tenure-track job and
since i was a cms student so
um i hope we can do some meta stuff
here but not too much i guess i think
that'll be a lot of fun uh yeah
already instructed andrew to delete
every possible copy there is of my
master's thesis
no it's so good yeah let's get going so
i guess
one of the two ways in which cms really
shaped my thinking and i'm sure
the same for you lana is um a to think
comparatively
which meant quite um simply to think
across media forms
to think across historical moments and
to think across cultural contexts
and the other key sort of phrase that
has stayed with me is to think about
media always as in transition
so with those two things in mind i
thought we could open the conversation
by
uh having you reflect a little bit uh on
the conjuncture
of in terms of when you began thinking
about this topic itself
as a project you wanted to pursue and
sort of have a
a temporal bracket of sorts so it was
around 2708 when you started actively
imagining this as a dissertation project
and eventually a book
coming out of the financial crisis that
we were plunged into at that moment in
the us
and now here we are in 2020 at a very
different political conjunction but
which has also some serious financial
and political ramifications as well
so with these two bookends in mind could
you just start off by telling us a
little bit about
how that moment uh led to your even
beginning to imagine this as a viable
long-term project yeah i
absolutely agree and have found that the
term
media and transition which i when i was
in cms
i was sort of like yeah yeah media in
transition it's the name of the books
that
you know thorburn and henry wrote and
that's the name of our conference blah
blah blah what does it even mean
um but then again and again it's
something i come back to
um and and this kind of
um analytical tool that says okay let's
look at
moments of media change we're not
interested so much in new media for the
sake of newness
um we're interested in moments of
you know disjuncture and and shifting
and if we really
zero in and focus in on those moments of
change you know what do we learn um
and that really is the primary analytic
for my um entire book like every there
is one kind of big
historical chapter that looks at moments
of media change
and looks at money as a payment or
rather looks at money as media
and then kind of touches down at key
moments of change
but then every other chapter that
follows
examines the a moment of newness but
also um
all of the the things that kind of led
up to that moment of newness
so absolutely i think and i think we'll
likely kind of circle back to that um as
we chat
but to answer your question and i think
this kind of
is interesting to think about the kind
of historiography
of um transition so you you mentioned
that i started
conceiving of this as a dissertation
project around 2007 2008.
and that's actually not true um i i
started conceiving as
a dissertation project probably closer
to
2011 2012 so you know i finished cms in
2009
i had written a thesis on counterfeit
luxury goods
and kind of regimes of ownership and
authorship
and then i started my phd that following
year
2009 2010 probably wasn't in the thick
of it
and until of thinking about
dissertations for another couple of
years
um but it's it
absolutely the moment that the
dissertation is born out of
is the 2008-2000 or 2007-2008 financial
crisis and a variety of other
immediate changes that happened at that
moment and it really is only
retrospectively
and this is why i speak of you know
historiography that 2008
becomes 2008. so 2008 probably wasn't
2008 until 2010
um although maybe 2020 might already be
2020.
um so thinking about like when we become
aware of of
moments as being moments all that being
said um
i started thinking the the year
2007-2008
marks an important moment for thinking
about money as a communication
technology because of a few
you know interrelated um factors
so we did as you mentioned had the 2008
global financial crisis
which i really believe
ignited a moment of kind of rethinking
money so
suddenly we had broad-based global
movements that sort of said
you know what are the you know like why
should
traditional governments and traditional
financial systems um
be the primary producers of
money um are there other ways to do the
economy and of course you know
thinking about occupy and those sort of
things that wasn't really until
2012 2013 so like the way history moves
is interesting
um and so yeah so we have this moment
where we were
kind of collectively rethinking the
economy i always go back to this one
onion article
um which you know sometimes it proves to
be true that onion kind of like speaks
the truth but
um that says you know it was a headline
that said
um the us economy or global economy
grinds to halt as everyone realizes
that money is nothing more than a shared
um delusion
and they this article describes this
like sudden awakening just like rippling
across the populace where suddenly a
bank robber is like why am i robbing a
bank
this is so dumb and uh someone about to
have their house foreclosed upon is like
oh i don't i don't have to leave my
house that's awesome um
but then and then they're like well cool
now that we know this what are we gonna
do and there's just a moment of like oh
wait a minute money actually serves like
a pretty
useful purpose for deciding how to
broker goods and services and how to
figure out how to communicate um in an
economy
and so i kind of think there's this like
moment of awakening but then this moment
of of like
okay when the rubber hits the road how
are we actually going to think about
building new systems that might be um
alternatives to
um the thing that we've suddenly
realized maybe we don't want so that's
that's there's that that that factor and
then also 2007 2008 was the emergence of
the
um iphone followed quickly thereafter
by um android um so
so suddenly we were carrying around in
our pocket you know these
what had previously been like fairly
sophisticated computers
that do a lot of the things that um we
need to kind of do money
with so um have some kind of uh
universal address book um hat like
such as facebook um which that year is
also the urban facebook kind of has the
tipping point of becoming
this like truly kind of mass scale
um uh system um
and keep account of records so you know
various
you know if you have an excel
spreadsheet and you have a way of
transmitting information and you have a
way of contacting someone you kind of
can like do money
and that's that's pretty much all you
need um in many ways and a whole
and then the hard part is the system for
authorizing um and making that
the information kind of socially
guaranteed to be valuable um
and then of course we have m-pesa which
was the um
you know the first large-scale uh
um mobile money system so there had been
attempts to do mobile money and mobile
payments
for a long time and um mostly in kenya
but also in other parts of sub-saharan
africa we had
the the you know the proof of concept
so um suddenly and so i traced that as a
moment where
a lot of the innovations that kind of
became fintech
um became crypto became all the things i
kind of study in my book
were kind of born so by the time i
finished the dissertation which was in
2000
i don't know 14 what did i finish yeah
new 2015
um you know i had been able to kind of
follow along
with the cohort of people who were
trying to rethink money from a bunch of
different angles who all got interested
in it around the same time
i did so it's a fortuitous time to study
uh transition as it happened yeah i mean
that's a great start and i think what
you've captured is the difficulties
involved in mapping a moment as it
unfolds
but then when you finally get to the end
of a dissertation and you turn it into a
book
you have that space to then step back
and carefully historicize it and then
up to that moment which you do
beautifully in the book and i'm just
going to read out a couple of sentences
as a way to
get deeper into it so at the very
beginning what i really like is the way
you
set things up offer a very clear
argument at the beginning
and then you offer this wonderful
structure for the whole book he said
this is a book about the cultural
politics
of transactional technologies it offers
a new way to think about money as a
communication medium dependent on
particular technologies
and then you go on to say that each
chapter takes up an essential mechanism
of payment
and explain how explains how it works
which you do beautifully
how it got to be that way how it's
changing and what implications those
changes may have
and for whom right and i read this and i
thought
especially in what you just explained it
could not have been
obvious as a phd student in a media and
communication department
that you could very quickly and easily
situate the question of money and
payment
within media and communication studies
it's not obvious at all to begin with
right and you turn to james carey and
some other domains of media theory
as a way to then think through a
structure give it a theoretical
scaffolding
so could you then take us to that next
step which is once you proposed a
dissertation did your advisor say that's
crazy
and then b how did you sort of how did
you work your way through different
disciplines to then come up with this
framework
and ground yourself in media and
communication studies instead of
going off into cultural anthropology or
sociology or so on
yeah so i um so as i mentioned i was
coming off of a
cms thesis where i was studying um
counterfeit luxury goods so like
fake bags um fake louis vuitton bags and
shoes and that sort of thing and i was
studying
the fan communities um who come together
um who are really kind of connoisseurs
of the fake
um mostly entirely online and they um
you know these are people who um
use global you know really kind of
interestingly like global
supply chains um today they're using
things like wechat and taobao
to like order direct from um you know
folks in china who are making like the
best fakes um and in many ways these
fakes are like
better than the real and they say things
like because they have like better
stitching they're actually handmade
whereas the real
the reels are no longer actually
handmade um and they say things like
you know anyone can walk into any anyone
with two thousand dollars can walk into
a louis vuitton store and buy the real
version
only i because i have the social network
the technical savvy and the depth of
expertise um
to understand what makes a perfect fake
um can buy the perfect fake and i'm part
of this community etc
and so i was really interested at that
moment in studying
kind of marketplaces as a culture and
um kind of the and and the the online
communities that are
that come up around markets and also the
the
oh and i'm i'm quite familiar with the
reddit uh group that
just got posted there's a few of those
so i need to do i would love to do an
update to that project um sooner rather
than later but
we'll see um and also kind of the
technologies that people use to kind of
do
markets so i was really attuned both
through cms but also through an interest
in kind of sds science and technology
studies and infrastructure studies um
to look not just at um
the way ideas information communities
circulate but the actual infrastructures
that allow them to circulate
um so i
had i became pretty interested in
economic anthropology at that moment
and was reading quite broadly in the
kind of ideas um
around the culture of economic practice
and then was attuned to thinking about
you know what those infrastructure like
how infrastructure played a role
fortunately um i went to university of
southern california's annenberg school
for my phd and fortunately
um i happened to be co-located
just uh about an hour away from bill
maher who's a
economic anthropologist at uc irvine um
who had been studying
payments and was really kind of the like
i i became really interested in payments
and payment systems and the
infrastructures of um
of economic practice and then just an
hour away was the only other person in
the world
who at that moment was actually
interested um in it
and we met and we were able to just be
like you know
have these long intense sessions where
we were just geeking out about the
things we knew
about the visa mastercard network or um
you know the intricacies of the way
various payment infrastructures worked
and at the time we sort of talked about
ourselves as like a field of two
um that is no longer true and that
wasn't even true at the time
but it was you know the people we knew
um so
and then the other thing i really had to
do though um and mary is very sweet to
to say you know you know this kind of
official
pedigree of like you know who's
anthropologist who's not i did have to
say though
you know i'm not an anthropologist my
training is not going to be
primarily anthropology my training is
going to be primarily in communication
um and then and then the question of
like communication versus media studies
is another one um but but nevertheless i
i i had to really almost use
my training and use the title of my phd
as an oblique strategy
um to think about you know what kind of
contribution i could make
um so so what i i came to think about
was this idea that
you know money is fundamentally
communicative
um you know a transaction is a
trans moving action a movement across a
movement from
one account to another um and whether
that happen and then and then we have to
attend to
the media or the kind of infrastructures
or technologies that
that allow that transaction to take
place or enable that transaction take
place
and then what and then ask questions
like what are the politics of those
infrastructures
um so while bill and others um
are uh are are thinking about it from
like
you know at one point bill and i were
having kind of these conversations and
he
i realized he brought to bear all of
this i i was always intimidated because
he's a
very senior scholar super genius um and
he knew all this stuff about the
anthropological record and i
didn't but then i realized oh wait a
minute like he's not thinking about it
in this kind of media studies and
communication way and i actually am
and all the ways that i had kind of been
taken taken for granted about my
training
um we're a totally new way to kind of
think about this
um so so yeah um
especially when you say that one of your
goals in this book is to
you know move beyond the taken for
grantedness that money is something that
symbolic and expressive
and it's really fantastic how you take
what you just said the transaction
and then you work it out in each chapter
and just for those of you who don't have
the book yet
each chapter works out a different
dimension a different sort of
a different logic of transaction let's
say with one chapter offering a
really wonderful short history i mean
this is really a model for how to write
a short history
and then you go through and say you know
questions of identity
politics memories publics and then
finally futures
and what i like is the real nice
narrative thread you have with this
notion of
transaction and you draw so fruitfully
on james carey
and what you actually managed to pull
off which is brilliant is to achieve a
sort of synthesis between the ritual and
the transmission views of communication
that we all sort of uh cite endlessly
but never quite
bring those two things together in our
own analytic frame which you do really
well
so i guess that leads to the next
question and there are
places which have bookmarked uh in my
copy which i'm going to return to every
now and then
you talk a little bit about
infrastructure but um i wish
i hope we can talk a little bit about
the citizenship part really get into
um and there's one bit on page 107
where you have this really evocative
line about
getting paid that the task for those who
hope to design how we get paid in the
future is to figure out how to maintain
all the things that
cash and so on i was wondering if we can
talk given our current context and also
2008 2009 have you also had a chance to
reflect on
not getting paid and how that also
figures in these kinds of transactional
um transactional spaces that we all
inhabit
uh given the global financial crisis and
given what we're all
sort of dealing with now yes and i think
that that question really
points um allah helps me point really
specifically to what i hope
is one of the key interventions of the
book which is we
tend to think about the politics of
money the politics of getting paid and
not getting paid
um in terms of quantity um and
distribution so
who has money who has not enough of it
who has too much of it
um and these are sort of economic
questions
um but there are also kind of
communicative questions we can ask
about the technologies of money that we
only really see
if we become attuned to thinking about
money as media money is a technology
um so i argue in that chapter about
getting paid
that one of the um you know that that
that not having
access to the money that you have and
not being able to use
the money that you have is as good as
not having any money at all
um and so so
and i use the example of a um
and i think you know this is a case i i
had to write about because i kept coming
back to it again and again but so i'll
just kind of briefly tell that story
um a story of a woman who
named eden alexander who was a cam girl
online sex worker
um who um had a medical emergency you
know very common a
very catastrophic reaction to a very
common medication um and found herself
um
unable to work essentially and you know
she doesn't didn't have health insurance
this was before the affordable care act
um
and found herself kind of in pretty dire
straits in the kind of american
health care system um and so
what her community did which is what
communities have always done is they
kind of passed the hat
to try to raise money um to defer the
costs of
uh of of her of her crisis
um and it being uh you know
the 20 teens um it was done through a
crowdfunding campaign
um and it the platform is one that is no
longer
no longer exists um but was specifically
um geared towards healthcare expenses
and
um so because she was you know minor
celebrity had lot you know had plenty of
twitter followers
um she was able to raise money fairly
quickly um
and one of her friends whose person or
community
set off tweeted um i will
offer a free pick set meaning
pornography um to anyone who donates a
hundred dollars or more
to eden's campaign eden's own twitter
account there's some questions about
whether or not
eden was the one who tweeted it because
she was in the hospital it doesn't
matter
retweeted that and then suddenly
eden got a ton of messages stating
that her cat her she had violated the
terms of service
of the of the um the platform
the uh and all donations
so and her her campaign had been
suspended and all donations had been
refunded um
and then there was again kind of a
you know huge backlash she had enough
twitter followers for it to be the kind
of
cause of the day um and another
crowdfunding campaign stepped in and
said oh
you know we'll be happy to help you
we'll step in and we'll
and that one also no longer exists but
they were trying to kind of make their
name off of being the um helpful
platform the good platform and this kind
of moment
um but that's not you know something
most people
have the acts you know the ability to do
we're not all able to kind of wield an
army of twitter followers to
do customer service on our behalf um
so uh when the you know people were sort
of examining and offering various hot
takes
um around what had happened you know
eden supporters somewhat
you know rightly said you know kind of
blamed the
um the crowdfunding campaign as being
like a group of tech bros who felt like
it was their right to um
create you know make moral evaluations
of who should be able to get money and
who shouldn't
um and then the crowdfunding campaign
said oh we
well tried to say like what actually
happened was when she retweeted the
offer for
pornography it became a transaction for
pornography
rather than a transaction for
crowdfunding so it became this kind of
financial moment
and we are required by our underlying
payments processor to not accept
and allow donation or um transactions
for pornography that's you know
part of a thing where like a taboo list
um
and then and then the payments processor
um we pay said oh actually we're not the
ones prohibiting it
it's our visa mastercard network
underneath um us prohibiting it so this
is kind of passing the buck of who
made the rules um that that ultimately
prohibited
um sex work um from being transactable
on the site um and
and so what i did and what i think
was really important and my kind of
training um which
allowed me to be able to do this was to
say okay what really happened here
why are the rules the such is that they
are
um and what i learned is that basically
in the kind of old system
of uh payments acquiring um
individual or merchants are able to
acquire payments
um well uh i'll say
acquirers meaning like the banks that
serve merchants
are able to kind of acquire payments on
behalf of merchants according to a
particular set of risk logics and risk
appetites
and if you are considered a high risk
merchant meaning
high risk for chargeback meaning high
risk that the customer that you have is
going to say i want my money back
um then you will get charged more for
your payments
um so there seems to be
belief i have not seen any actual
evidence this is actually true
that the selling of pornography of any
kind um
produces a higher rate of chargebacks
and the reason for this might be that
people say like oh it wasn't me
that bought that subscription it was my
kid or um
or you know sorry boss or spouse i
didn't make this transaction etc
or it could be that historically
pornography especially online
pornography is pretty scammy
um and you might like sign up for you
might think you're doing a one-time
payment but it winds up becoming this
recurring payment
um but for whatever reason it is
received wisdom in the payments industry
that if you want to receive payments for
pornography you have to pay more
um but in the platform economy
everything sort of becomes one size fits
all and rather than there being this
kind of bespoke
risk model on an individual merchant
basis that
um you know creates a market for risk um
in
the payments acquiring system uh it
becomes what becomes like a
a way of pricing variable kinds of
transactions
becomes a one-size-fits-all prohibition
as inscribed in terms of service
um there is no real way for
uh for any kind of platform to write
a bespoke um kind of or even
variable governance system it seems um
so they just say
all the things that used to be a little
bit more expensive or a little bit
strange or
or a little bit um outside the norm for
the way
we do payments are just going to be
completely prohibited
um so it's this importing wholesale
without
really considering it um of of one risk
model
into this a new kind of risk model that
created this misalignment
that created what was ult what could
have been a quite catastrophic situation
for um this person for eden um
and indeed is a catastrophic situation
um for countless people who suddenly and
without real
um with without any real ability to
predict it
um suddenly lose access to their
payments um
so for me i really
have been interested in how like people
are
not just denied money like just don't
have
you know enough money but rather are
denied access to the money
that they have and and what are the
reasons like
actual reasons that that happens for um
i mean another example
is like in the united states under using
ebt which is our kind of welfare cards
um you you can only use your ebt payment
card to buy certain kinds of
merchandise so if you walk into a store
you can't buy a hot
chicken um even though rochester
chickens are a loss leader for
uh supermarkets and are really great for
um you know
some a working person who may have a
family they want to feed you know such
as
most people who receive welfare um they
um they often you know so
so you can't buy a hot chicken but you
can buy a hot chicken that has been
chilled
and placed in a chilled um refrigerator
system
um because that is no longer hot food
that becomes cold food and therefore
you're able to buy it using your ebt
card um so
what interests me in kind of thinking
about the kind of like
social justice questions or political
questions of payments is not j
or of money is not just how you have
money or if you have money
but how the money you have works and how
the way it works
reinscribes um or produces new
kinds of injustices new kinds of
inequalities
and and thinking about those
inequalities as
questions of access and questions of
kind of informational and communicative
um you know sticking points
yeah you have this really evocative line
at one point in that chapter where you
talk about
the profound implications of what you
call losing the citizenship
of a transactional community and that
line
um really gets to the racialized and
gendered sort of dimensions of what you
just laid out so so wonderfully well
and i was wondering if given that you
started this project in la and you were
going back and forth between iran and
other spaces and la itself was a space
this notion of losing the citizenship of
a community
of transaction of moving across spaces
and moving over time
um i was wondering if there's a link
between migrants migration
immune systems that were part of your
thinking at the time
where others perhaps in your community
of economic anthropology meets media
studies
or others working on it or how have you
seen that emerge
and i asked that in part because there's
this really amazing piece that you have
about memory and you say money is
memory and those three words money
memory migration
really come together in very powerful
ways for me and i wanted to ask you to
reflect a little bit
on those three keywords yeah so when i
think about money is memory
um i come at it from a few different
perspectives so i think about
you know it's it's interesting that the
idea that money is memory is something
that occurs
across um many different
fields of scholarship who are not at all
in communication with each other so for
example
economists like kind of game theoretic
economist talk about money as memory
because in in a kind of game theory
context and kind of an economic
experiment
um you can you can either have
a tally system so like a system of
of keeping accounts that everyone can
see a kind of memory system
or you could have a money system meaning
tokens that people exchange
and in a c in a economic
experiment um either way the
whether you have a memory system or a
money system it kind of produces
the same outcomes in game play so in
that sense like
money is a literal like
exo memory which is a a term that
actually nancy bain
uh i got from nancy baim a science
fiction book nancy bam wrote but it's
this kind of collective memory or
external memory system
um that we use to remember
in a you know economic sense um
our transactions you know i have we have
transacted i have paid you
now you have the money and i don't and
we both remember that that transaction
has occurred
um but then anthropologists who are not
at all in communication with you know
this particular stream
of of game theory will also write that
money as memory
and they mean that yes it is this way of
keeping track of our inter obligations
but they mean that in much more of a
um uh a kind of sense of of kind of
socio
the kind of socio-cultural dimensions of
that um
and and so you know vivian as elzer and
economic sociologists talk about these
kind of like spheres of exchange and
networks well they all there's like some
people there's like
some people say network some people say
spheres some people say circuits etc
um but the way that um money kind of
traces
the tessellations of our inter
obligations to each other
um and then thinking about the question
i mean i would love to kind of
you know hear your perspective and just
because
you're have thought so many fascinating
things about this but i'd love to you
know kind of hear how it intersected for
you on the question of migration
um but i will say that many
economics anthropologists had have
studied money systems as they relate to
remittances
and as they relate to kind of like
development
um and and very few
very little attention had been paid to
the
kinds of meaning and politics of payment
systems in the united states
um as though the unless i think it's an
error
that you know so we tend to repeat it
again against scholars but as though
um economic transactions in
primitive societies are more meaningful
and
um economic transactions in the west are
you know so much more economic and so
much more uncoupled
um from you know social uh aspects um
and so i wanted to kind of resocialize
western money and northern money and
and and demonstrate um the contours of
the kind of inequalities inscribed
therein
um so so yeah um
yeah i want to hear what you have to say
i can i can chime in as well but even
before we get to that
um i'm also mindful of the time and yeah
so we have to take questions
so uh keeping in mind that we wanted
this to uh be oriented towards cms grad
students and
other early career scholars and phd
students listening in
one of the other bits of your book that
i thought was worth
reflecting on a little bit was the sheer
range of
methodological tools you had to pull
together
because you were crossing across these
different theoretical domains
so in one sense as a good media study
scholar
you really pulled together different
kinds of artifacts and read them as
texts you do these really close thematic
analyses
of advertisements um like
credit card sort of surfaces like these
um that i'm holding up to the screen uh
but you also sort of trace
process um so it's almost like i've i've
read it as a process geography kind of
book
where you're going through the life
cycle of a certain kind of transaction
that gets going
and then you're going to follow it
through its lifestyle and along the way
you're going to do deep dives into
different moments
moments of interaction and which
institutions which actors are then
come into play which networks get
activated and so on
um so could you say a little bit about
that dimension of your project what were
some of the challenges did you have to
learn new methods
or did you have to re-tool some methods
uh
to bring as tarleton said in the chat
window
to bring this communication perspective
to a very new object that
media and kimcom studies has not tended
to take into account
so i mean in some ways i think this
circles back to the question of
learning about an object as a
community formed around it so you know i
came to thinking about money at a time
when a lot of people were thinking about
money and kind of a lot of people were
reimagining the infrastructures of money
i mean the term fintech basically
um came of age during the writing of my
book um
certainly cryptocurrency and all that um
emerged during the writing of my
dissertation and then book um
and so i was effect i effectively
thought of myself as an ethnographer
um but i was an ethnographer of
communities who
were rediscovering or rather were
discovering
their the genealogy and the history of
the thing that they were interested
in so like me lots and lots of
of entrepreneurs artists activists um
said you know we need to re you know i'm
fascinated by money i'm not sure why but
i'm fascinated by it and i
and i'm and i'm desperate to rethink it
um
and so let me now now i have to suddenly
learn everything about the way the visa
mastercard network works or like
the way the automated clearinghouse
works and so
like like them i thought okay like how
do people
how do people in this industry learn
about
these like really boring systems and the
answer to that was they go to
industry boot camps like um where you
learn you spend one week doing a super
deep dive
in how um how these
kind of legacy systems work and
everybody else around me was either
employed by a legacy system like a big
bank of views mastercard etc
and they were i was literally doing the
employee training
that people who work in this industry do
or they were learning about them because
they wanted to like disrupt and
revolutionize them
um and then there and i was sort of
there learning about the thing but also
doing an ethnography of all the people
around me
um and then um like many of the people
around me
there was the opportunity to kind of
discover histories i i joke that i am
unfortunately uh or for better or for
worse like probably one of the world's
experts on the diners club card which
was the first
uh third party uh universal third party
payment card that emerged in the 1950s
and 60s
um and to kind of and and so so banner's
club
still exists um it's more popular in
some countries than in others
but it has gone through a number of
different mergers and acquisitions and
is now
i think most recently owned by um
discover
um and it was purchased by discover for
its international network
but during many of these kind of
transitions
um its company archive was lost so
another thing
that i've learned about um is that many
large companies have their own
archive have their own librarian have
their own archivist um and those can be
tremendous
tremendous uh uh sources of information
for thinking about the kind of um
history of technology and history of
business um
but diners club have been lost at one
point it had been outsourced to a
company that
now i think also no longer exists called
um the history company no the history
factory
um that was meant to be a steward of of
various corporate archives but
um someone who stopped paying the
diana's club bill at some point and
this kind of went off and and smoke so
um i
wound up doing kind of and this is
something i've learned
a lot about from kevin driscoll who's my
partner but also a media historian
um which is the kind of ebay archive the
kind of ebay histories
where you set up your ebay alerts and
you buy everything
um that uh you know for a couple bucks
um that relates to kind of the early
ephemera of the thing you're interested
in
so through that i discovered for example
um
that early diners club cards
had these kind of books and this is
actually i have a
very short piece which i'd be happy to
see anybody which is in my edited
collection from mit press called paid
about the diners club um about the
diners club and the way that
um the card itself was one
innovation but really in order to
um find how to use a diners club find a
way
the way to you the only way to use the
dire scope card was to know where it was
accepted
and the only way to know where it was
accepted was to um have these kind of
guidebooks that told you
where and you could look up like any
town anywhere in america
um and know that your card would be
accepted there um
and so i and so i kind of begin to
realize from kind of looking at the
books which i only learned about because
i found them on ebay
um that they were kind of the key
innovation and they were the kind of
key wayfinding tool um for the
transactional community
of um of of the diners club
card and so in the short piece that i
wrote for mit the mit book um
i kind of compared it to the green book
so the you know the negro motorist
screen book
which helped um you know
african-american travelers
navigate the um segregated united states
um and find safe harbor while on the
road
um and i then discovered
just by kind of pivoting into kind of
more traditional historical
um approaches you know just like
newspaper archival searches
um that at in the um
african-american uh press of the
mid-century of which there are many
african-american newspapers
there is a lot of talk about how um you
know on the road
there was no way to pay for anything um
except
through something like a diners club
card because
you know there were no major um bank
networks there were
uh you know you couldn't go to bank
america on any corner and pull money of
an atm they hadn't been invented yet
um it was pretty hard to uh get a
merchant to accept an out-of-town check
because they it would be pretty hard to
kind of track down um
you know it was easy to do check fraud
um and so the diners club card basically
allowed people to travel
and be accepted to kind of book places
you know pay for hotels pay for rental
cars etc
and in the african american press there
was a lot of talk about how african
americans were not really able to take
advantage
of the innovation of the diners club
card because they
faced a new kind of de facto um
discrimination when they showed up
um they had you know to pay for their
motel room and the clerk said
oh diners club card well if you could
just get
cash we'd be happy to give you a room um
and so
these kind of new layers of
privatization on top of the kind of
transactional
um technology of money created new
opportunities for
new and innovative kinds of
discrimination and racism um
so and the only way i would have known
about that or the only way i was able to
figure that out was by kind of
circulating around and around through
the kind of
pivoting between ebay history to more
traditional forms of history
and the only way i really began to think
about the diners club was from
pulling from um the kind of ethnographic
ethnography of industry contexts so
you have to kind of constantly be
pivoting between different kinds of
approaches and just sort of
um i mean i think back to a piece i
actually read in cms which was
um the fisher michael fisher and george
marcus's like multi-sided ethnography
um which just encourages you to think
about everything ethnographically
whether it's historical work or other
kinds of like
um you know looking deeply at documents
and
and follow threads however they need to
be um
followed i also began to think of myself
as doing like an ethnography of pdfs
um because so many of the standards um
of these systems um whether they're like
the visa mastercard guidebook or like
any number of cryptocurrency white
papers are inscribed as pdfs
um so like engaging with that um
that network of of kind of non-human
actors that
uh guide these spaces was also like a
really important part of my work
i'm glad you referred to marcus and
fischer yeah mode of historical
anthropology
and the idea that i think i read the
same article too
i may have been in william eureki's
class about multi-sightedness not being
just endlessly sort of
multiplying the number of sites but to
think of
each site in a very very careful way and
how that each side is implicated in a
network of other forces and factors
some humans are non-human and i guess
i'll
close by saying that one of the real
pleasures of your book
is you you manage to intersect with so
many different emerging subfields
platform studies critical infrastructure
studies media industry studies critical
race studies and so on
and you managed to pull those threads
uh into chapters as in when you need to
get into certain crucial conversations
that are ongoing
but at the same time manage to stay
focused on this narrative thread about
transaction and that is no easy task
um so i guess i'll end with um this
question about
transfo writing your first book right
it's a monumental thing to do so
congratulations again it's such a great
achievement
and to do it so beautifully is really no
mean task
and so can you tell us for everybody
listening in especially
uh grad students uh early curious
scholars make struggling their way
through that first
book what were some of the challenges
what were some of the pleasures
and if you could even give us like a
glimpse into those
moments of sheer joy where you realize
that's it
finally for all these bloody years now i
get it after eight long years
uh yeah just tell us a little bit about
that process well i'm not sure
if i have felt
arctic release just that oh i got it
done i mean
it's i got it done right i got it done
but i don't know that i always feel that
i got it done right
um but i mean i i also just have to say
you know
when you mention kind of the litany of
of
um sub emergent subfields that i draw
from i mean a big part of that
is the network of people who i have had
the tremendous
um you know good fortune and privilege
of
you know being exposed to some of whom
are here today
um and you know certainly kind of
kendall square between my cms time and
my microsoft research time
um has been incredibly uh you know
important to the kind of formation
of of my intellectual um life and
as it emerged in this book um and
i guess that both of that happened kind
of before and after the dissertation
um but i would say
i you know in
the exciting structure of the book for
me or one of the
the the exciting
ways of untangling a puzzle was to kind
of think about
um following through the actual
mechanisms of transactions so
um getting paid kind of processing those
payments
paying and then the kind of data that
emerges and test lights out from there
um and then actually being able to look
and deeply attend and i could
i go on for quite some length in the
book and could go on
in you know chattering about it for even
longer um
about the actual material processes that
underlie
um the way the the way
transactions um actually function in the
kind of like baseline
visa mastercard payment system um and
breaking the book down
into a chapter that that chapters that
examine
each of those processes um and really
giving myself permission to not spare
um or you know to be willing to kind of
give the technical detail as much
um of a close read um as
i as i felt they needed was really
freeing
um i often am frustrated frankly by
um by scholarship that talks about
algorithms or talks about you know
technologies as though
they were all one thing or as though
like you know algorithms what are they
we don't know but they're bad um which
that's nobody here
um but but i think that that tends to be
a
a problem and so like really really
digging
into the technologies themselves um and
then
exploding them out um was something that
yeah i'm glad there's sorry i'm
monitoring the thing on the side um
uh you know that that was allowing
myself the time and the space to really
unpack the technologies
and and treat them at you know as though
they were cultural texts and cultural
artifacts which they are
um was something that uh i
i was i'm grateful to be able to have
had and i'm grateful to readers who are
willing to uh
spend the time to actually read some of
the boring stuff
that i find so fascinating no no
not boring at all if anything i think
it's the richness of that detail
that then allows the reader to then step
back and really um
come to terms with the fact that it's
out of these details
that the social life of transaction
really emerges
and what's what's held together
throughout
is what you just said which is um where
he said what becomes newly material
that's another phrase from your book
that really stayed with me
and you and you sort of do the the
attention to the material dimensions of
different different processes like you
said of paying getting paid
paying somebody when mowing somebody
something and so on
while not allowing those material
dimensions
to somehow over determine the social so
the both of those terrains remain
autonomous in your framework
and you manage to do manage to hang on
to both of them
without necessarily sort of you know
making facile
directionality arguments about this
leading to the other you know it's
in that sense it is i think an exemplar
of doing the kind of conjunctual work
that
a stuart hall might say like have put
everything into context
keep the two things together in one
frame and see where the story leads you
right which allows you to i think be
really
open to new insights rather than going
in and saying this is what venmo is
doing
um so yeah i couldn't recommend this
book highly enough
um honestly this is sort of an example
of media and transition
all of you on this uh go get a copy lana
will
when when when a book tour happens when
a real newton-wide book tour happens she
will have to come to wherever you are
and sign the book for you
uh but i did have someone on um twitter
offer to buy a signed copy of the book
via bitcoin um and then yeah so i'm open
to that but then in the dms
they were like oh actually can i not
give you bitcoin because like i don't
know if you know this but bitcoin's
pricing is like highly variable and so
why would i
pay for a book i'm like you're about to
um so yeah i will take bitcoin for the
book yeah
i'm sure there are lots and lots of
questions uh waiting in the chat queue
that andrew can uh perhaps moderate or
score depending on who
wants to take that goal but please
everybody join me in congratulating lana
again on this
uh on this terrific achievement and yeah
thank you for questions yeah thank you
all for um
you know allowing us to do this kind of
experimental
chat um i i hope it was a little bit you
know i know we all have zoom fatigue so
i hope
something a little bit more interactive
was uh more interesting and thank you so
much for askwin for
asking such um insightful and and and
very kind questions
yeah let's yeah let's hear it yeah let's
see what else is there
in keeping with the spirit of this let's
start with see whether there are
questions from the students first before
uh before i go to the chat list or the
qa
um is that thomas do you have here is
that
uh you're raising your hand yes go ahead
um hi i'm damas i'm a first year cms
grad student
and so i'm interested in well obviously
you look at me in transition which is
what we
most of us do and i'm interested in how
to how do you study the ship between
like novelty and continue
continuity i feel like sometimes we're
like saying everything is new and at the
same time we're saying like everything
is the same
always yeah so the a phrase that i had
to
excise from the book because i used it
too many times was
but there is a longer history here um
and
and so i do think that kind of looking
at the new
and then situating the new or looking at
this moment of transition which um
you know it knew at any given moment and
then
doing this kind of genealogical work to
kind of figure out
what are the necessary histories that
need to be known
and then i have found it really useful
so i think about money
um one of the analytics that the kind of
money
money as a object of study has gotten me
um is to think about the way money
creates kind of shared futures
so we only use a form of money and
accept a form of money because we
believe it'll be worth something
tomorrow
um or the next day or the next day um
and we
are and that is you know a kind of
performance of the
um of the acceptance of the authority
of whatever um bodies authorize that
value of that money so
you know i might feel a lot of anxiety
about the death of american democracy
but i'm still willing to
accept um you know and use us dollars as
payments because i don't feel that much
anxiety about it um but nevertheless i
get questions from um interviewers i've
gotten questions from multiple different
journalists this week about people you
know moving all their money into bitcoin
ahead of the us election
um so it so that kind of analytic that
kind of way that money
creates a shared future or a sense of a
shared future among those who use it
became a way for me to kind of think
about
future um so how do
the people who use a shared money form
understand a shared past
what do they not know about that shared
past um what do i need to know about the
shared past to understand this like
moment of
of um change and then how does that um
give an object project into a future and
what what kinds and like what array of
possible futures are made available
by the object of study and the community
that surrounds it
um and so your whatever your topic is is
going to be very different but i think
whatever your topic
is will yield its own um
ways of structuring shared past and
shared futures and understanding
um these kind of like shared presence
and as long as you are able
to endeavor to think analytically about
all of that
you'll kind of i think that's like a
pretty useful way to kind of
deal with that question great thank you
diego i see your hand up um uh yeah
uh thank you lana and aspen for the
conversation
uh i i have a uh a question as
somebody who is also interested in the
kind of like intersection of media and
economics
and uh so how
does somebody from uh mega studies
engage with
economies because like economics is this
really well
fenced field or at least it seems to be
this really well fenced field
that is uh really worth but uh the
practitioners and the
scholars in that field right and and at
least in my experience it seems to me
that they see kind of like media size as
okay there are these
like scholars are they are only looking
at the cultural dimensions of the
economic practices right but but there
is more to it right and i think that
what i get from from the from the new
conversation is that
there is always like material semiotic
dimension of the practices of economic
right and
that this dimension have like actual
consequences in our economy right
but how do we show them that this that
this dimension has
is important right that's what i keep
wondering about
yeah i mean i guess my answer to that
to use the language of economics is to
say what is the utility
of convincing them um and there may
indeed be
utility um but
the but then ultimately kind of what is
the outcome
that you want to have like to what
extent
you know i've definitely had the feeling
that i really wanted to be more
respected by the economists that i've
interacted with
but i ultimately don't get anything of
that much use to me from being respected
by
economists um and um
and then if the question is okay
economists have tremendous power
and they've been able to um marshall
their kind of like
weird uh non-empirical um way of of
doing theory um
into uh a kind of like political power
um
you know maybe that's useful but then do
you have to go through them
to get what you need or to do what you
need to do
so i think it's like you know figure out
what you want to get out of it and then
you know go on from there i will say for
me and this is unique to my case
um economists a very small group of
economists are some of the only people
who are
have historically been interested in
payment systems because they're
interested in two-sided markets
um and so there are
like people who want to geek out about
payment systems um who are in the field
of economics and they're excited
to talk to me because um i'm one of the
only people who shares that interest
um so and and who is like reading their
papers
from 20 years ago um so i do think that
i do think that that you know you find
common ground that you
want to stand on with those disciplines
um
and then you figure out why you want to
interact with them beyond that
i mean i don't know i'm i might be too
early in my career to give you
more of a um of an answer than that
um but i think kind of like living in
and performing your confidence
i some of you will know what i'm talking
about here but
i i i know i have met
economists in my life literally um who
are uh who i have now turned
this like i there's a particular
economist that i know and i turn this
mantra where i say what would his name
is not as one but let's pretend his name
is oz
where anytime i do anything in life i
say what would aswin do
what would aswin expect what kind of
like privilege would this economist
expect to be like
dropped at their feet and then that
gives me the power to say you know
like what try i try to use that to um
um empower myself to behave as an
economist would
so um and you know it doesn't always
work
most of the time it doesn't work but
it's um it's important to kind of
destabilize the kind of accepted
regimes of academic authority
[Laughter]
uh kelly
hi thank you for the talk um i have kind
of an analogous question which is
what has been your interaction with the
like tech enthusiasts
silicon valley dudes who want to remake
payments and have
have you had any discussions about your
work or do you hope to like change minds
and if so how and
yeah that's an interesting question so i
um
started as i've mentioned like in this
space when the space was kind of gearing
up
and early on you know there weren't that
many people interested in
um in this kind of i mean there were but
it was a smaller community
and so early on i was invited to give
lots and lots of talks to like
fintech groups and bitcoin groups and
that sort of thing um
some of which sat at the intersection of
academia and activism and some of which
didn't
um and the that was like a
important like ethnographic opportunity
for me to kind of
try to figure out how to be a critical
expert in this space when
when i in fact i was quite early on in
my work um
and it sort of speaks to the question of
like empowerment and authority where
like they didn't know what they were
talking about either so
i could kind of like marshal my own
ability to and and also really think
about
what could be interesting for these
groups like what could i bring to bear
and then an interesting thing happened
which is i wasn't saying anything
that was like monetizable um or that was
like
um fed the hype machine and if anything
i was kind of a hype
killjoy um early on and they were like
oh no
we don't invite her again um and then a
kind of interesting
thing happened where like we all ride
these like waves of hype cycles
and suddenly it's like cool to be
critical about
um these things again and so now
fortunately corresponding with my book
but also unfortunately corresponding
with a global
pandemic i'm now getting lots of new
invitations to kind of be the kind of
critical voice which they kind of now
decide that they they need to have um
which is cool um and then the other
piece is that like
asking the question like sincerely
asking the question like
what do industries and what are you know
activists and you know people who want
to try to make change from one direction
another what do they actually need to
know
um has proven to be a really useful
analytic for me um like i found myself
studying industries
but the industry isn't very interested
in learning about themselves
and so i had to kind of think for whom
is learning about this industry
interesting is it interesting to people
is it interesting to um you know users
of payment systems whether which we all
are um and then i had to think like
maybe not really so like what is
interesting and to whom
and then how do i kind of use that to
kind of put it all together
to create a book that is
kind of interesting to someone um and so
now it's an interesting thing where i
think you know the industries
are interested in hearing critique but
they're also interested in hearing about
history
um and then i i do hope
that the kind of like users at large are
interested in
in learning about how these kind of
systems actually work
and thinking about ways that people who
kind of sit at the intersection of user
and perhaps like
um change maker um
can kind of think past the kind of easy
stories
about like all good all bad and kind of
dig into some of the
um the the kind of details um i think
one of the most important things to me
to kind of communicate to
at least the kind of startup community
and the kind of crypto community
has been to um really attend to
and really think about how much human
labor
um and of course you know you can hear
traces of all the interlocutors that are
some of whom are in this room that i've
had over the years but
um you know that that
that rep new kinds of disintermediation
um of financial transactions via things
like blockchain
don't suddenly make things happen by
magic um
but rather are when they work if they
work which they usually don't
um they're the outcome of of a lot of
like human effort and
and to try to get the industry to think
about
how discovering hidden systems
and how important they are through the
process of remaking them
doesn't mean doesn't have to mean
resubmerging them
as though um all of the kind of
infrastructural care work
that went into producing them um was
instead
kind of this like the outcome of a um
you know technological magic if that
makes sense so
so yeah i think like always keeping in
mind who
um who would care and like
and like what your different audiences
are and what you can tell them
and and then think about and then also
think about like what
um the key takeaways would be for the
kind of
most empowered stakeholders um
you know might be for you
but yeah having to be like what do i
really
am i bringing to anybody has been like a
really really useful
way for me to figure out um what i could
actually
bring to anyone
thanks um so uh i unless i see another
question from a student
um for the sake of since this is
recorded
it's sort of my job to sort of read
questions
out loud just so that they get heard um
the chat
by the way is full of your fans and all
sorts of uh
i'm not surprised all sorts of sort of
uh enthusiastic supporting
comments i actually sort of do you see
one genuine question there from mary
gray
um which is do you consider platforms
like venue as
re-socializing of money yeah so if we
think about
venmo so venmo is talked about as you
know
for almost probably most of you know
what venmo is um oftentimes when i talk
to international audiences or
you know um older like adult audiences
and you're adults but you know what i
mean
um yeah i i have to kind of explain what
venmo is because it's something that's
like
very widely used among people under 30
in the united
states but not at all used um beyond
that
um and it's basically just makes
payments into a social feed
so you can um you attach
annotations to your payment um and then
you can also
surveil um the payments that uh other
folks in your
network are making or in public are
making um so
it is often talked about overtly as a
payments i mean as a social media system
as the
this attempt to um you know make money
into something that is social
sort of make money social and in fact i
remember having a conversation with a
very um well-known payments consultant
um at a big payments industry
um trade show and she was like you know
people have been trying to make
p2p kind of peer to person-to-person
transactions
happen for 20 years and who knew
all it would take would be to be able to
add emojis to it
um and i was like yeah but also you're
right like who knew
that money sort of like wanted to be
social um
and and that by like like allowing us to
kind of surface the sociality of money
would kind of make it something that
would you know people actually wanted to
to do and use
at the same time of course you know when
we say money is social
um it can kind of only be social in the
kind of silicon valley meaning of the
term
and so when you when you hear people in
those industry spaces talk about money
is social
what they really mean if they're like
saying oh we're doing social payments
what we really mean is that they're
doing payments whose main
um you know monetizable monetizability
comes through social media
data um so there's this like interesting
intersection where
you know silicon valley rediscovers that
money is in fact social
only through the process of enclosing
that sociality
um as something that can be commoditized
um
for in one way or another um i am though
i will say and i just want to give a
quick plug to this i
am really excited about tim huang's new
book about um
for what it's called but it's basically
about how social
data might be the next like big bubble
because like
there's only so many ways we can do
predictive analytics to
drive more advertising um and that you
know it might be kind of like the big
lie
that undergirds like all the systems
that we like and enjoy
um so i i i'll be very curious to see if
we ultimately do have uh
some kind of crash around that and then
you know what happens
how do we think about the sociality of
money and sociality of other um
you know other platforms that we've
invested so much of our lives in
um if we they suddenly are discovered to
be less
profitable than we imagine yeah yeah and
the
um i mean to marry
mary's question also sort of prompts the
uh observation that
the default publicness at the heart of
um
platforms like wenmoe and many others
and default publicness has been written
about quite a bit right
is that something that becomes uh
the focus for you when it comes to
thinking about
uh both the challenges but also the real
risks of
that mode of publicness yes yeah and
what's at stake
when communities that aren't in the
venmo ecosystem
uh don't get uh or don't become part of
the imaginary of silicon valley tectos
right
and so here i'm thinking back to our
brief back and forth about
migration meets payment systems i'm
wondering if this
i don't know this much but i'm wondering
if there's a
real opportunity there to do some deep
historical work where
boundary zones uh and i'm looking at
vivek ball's
uh work here in a sense that when a
group of migrants land on the shores
of some space and when there is simply
no commensurability
between different forms of money that
are circulating in that community
both of which happen to be marginalized
within the american racial system
what happens then so i'm wondering if
that sort of deep historical work is
also crucial if we are to recognize
the very real limits of the imaginations
of
silicon valley um other kind of tech
spaces like akra in khana bangalore
india you know or
sort of state driven initiative so yeah
not to put you on the spot
no well so in terms i'll just give a
quick shout out to um an
art piece um called public by default by
an artist named hang doo thi
duke which is referenced in my book
where she looks at kind of the humans of
venmo
um where and she uses she downloads like
all venmo transactions from 2017 using
their public api
and uses it not to um you know find
terrorists or
stop fraud or whatever but instead to
kind of paint these portraits of
the of people and the kind of human
lives behind the venmo transactions
and i think that her and her piece is
meant to be cautionary so it's meant to
say
you know look at all the things i can
learn about you
through venmo um and hear all these
compelling reasons and so easy to just
change your settings so just do it
but at the same time the piece like
really straddles this line where she
shows how kind of like poignant and like
real um
these like moments of transaction are
and it perfectly
for me oscillates between the
um you know the very real sociality of
payment and money
but also the kinds of um dangers of
of of living in this like newly um
public
way of kind of publicly doing
transactions um
and the other piece i want to mention
about that though is that for me
in some ways the advertising piece is is
the main way we think about monetizing
the internet but actually
the primary uses of um
payments data at least for payment apps
winds up being
operational so like predictive analytics
that like the kind of eden alexander
story i told
um uh prevent against alleged fraud
alleged violations of
terms of service and that kind of thing
so they wind up being these kind of like
um like they are used
the ultimately transaction data is used
to
power um and animate the transaction
systems themselves
um and so then the problem then becomes
these moments when they
stop working they they break down you
can't access your money you can't pay
with your money
um and and so
and and those those you know ruptures
happen because
of the um data produced by the systems
themselves so i think in some ways like
it's not so much that the data is or the
transactions are
viewable or surveillable but then like
how they're used and who makes sense of
them
i mean if you think about venmo vemmo is
the most public
um of you know transaction systems it's
the only one that i know of that has
like a really solid public api
um whereas others like you know
facebook and um google tend to be more
like data hoarders
um so like kind of what happens like
what kinds of what kinds of degrees of
publicity
and privacy are are useful if and for
what ends but to your question
um about transnation transnationality
this isn't exact i do think i absolutely
think more work needs to be done
along the historical lines you describe
but the thing it reminds me of
is um is two anecdotes that wind up in
the book which is
the way that people continue to use
money systems that are based in one
place
even as they transit to the to another
place so my students always tell me
about how
when you know what i teach class called
money median technology where we
lay all this out and again and again
they say it's so interesting i've heard
this exact same story again and again
that when i was in study abroad or when
i went abroad for the summer
my friends and i and my friend group had
one designated person who handled the
money
meaning handled the money of whatever
locale they were in
um trafficked in euros or pesos or
whatever
um whereas we all settled up in the
background using venmo
so we were all living in the kind of
this micro transactional community and
we had one kind of
envoy into the um you know transactional
world around us
and so this kind of experience of being
this like
fumbling um maladapted user
of a for foreign money was was something
they didn't really get to experience
because they were primarily
living within the kind of safe harbor of
something they understood which was
venmo
and all of those venmo transactions were
settling up
on cloud computers that were assigned to
united states and therefore they
they may have left the united states but
their money never did
um and similarly there are you know with
wechat if we think about
um you know china um you know there is a
a chinese restaurant across the street
from the university of virginia
where wechat is accepted um and wechat
pay is accepted
and and chinese students will look at
wechat to see the
kind of moments to see the specials of
the day and transact entirely with
wechat
in this um with this restaurant and
amongst themselves
um and similarly wechat can be used at
um
all caesar's own casinos in vegas um so
when i was at these um money trade shows
uh in vegas
i saw large groups of chinese tourists
transacting entirely in wechat except
for with gambling because you're not
allowed to use it to buy gambling chips
um that's the one
prohibition um fully
remaining within the kind of
communicative world and transactional
world of
china even as they travel beyond so i'm
really interested
in how payment and this kind of goes
back to the diners club thing thinking
about like payment as a wayfinding tool
payment as a tool of geography
um remakes geographies in ways that
don't simply map to territoriality like
what does it mean to
be somewhere um and and what does it
mean to be somewhere
even as most of your communications
including your financial communications
are happening somewhere else so to speak
no absolutely there's a history to be
told there's a story to be told about
like you said with the person who
handles money for all the study abroad
students
mediating personas perhaps right
money handlers and i'm thinking about
the grocery stores that i relied on and
the grocery store owner who could
mediate for me
uh basically remittances for you know
through the 90s
which have now disappeared from a
certain kind of cultural geography and
the geography of urban
sort of you know cities with whatsapp
with wechat and so on
so this is interesting that's what i
meant when i said
how do we recover that those kinds of
imaginaries of
relationships across space being
sustained by
networks of payments that tech bureaus
in silicon valley
a neither have the interest nor the
inclination to grasp
that form of sociality right so that's
why i was turning to
vivek and wondering if bengali harlem
has stories about
payments and money as a crucial form of
sociality for uh
the kinds of people who landed up in
harlem at the turn of the century but
yeah anyway sorry
yeah well one thing i will say about
harlem i just want to say one thing
about harlem at the turn of the century
rather harlem in the well
manhattan and the post-bellum period is
that in the united states
the um state issued currency was not
fully consolidated until well after the
civil war
um so if you were entering manhattan
whether as an immigrant from the
hinterlands in the united states or from
anywhere
you suddenly had to navigate a
very cacophonous monetary ecosystem and
david henkin
who's a a historian has a really great
book called city reading
that's about all the different forms of
reading the largely illiterate
um population of major cities had to do
and meaning he means new york um in the
18
19th century and being able to say okay
this banknote is real this banknote is
fake this banknote is real but it's from
a bank that went out of business
this banknote is actually issued from a
private bank
that would be good in philadelphia but
probably isn't good in
um in new york and having to kind of end
or be like this one's probably not good
but i guarantee
someone else will take it was a crucial
way of being street smart
and i think and this is kind of like a
big takeaway that we didn't really talk
about from the book is that
you know people often ask me what the
future of money is and i don't think
state issue currencies are going
anywhere
i don't think cash necessarily is going
anywhere but
what i do think where we'll be seeing is
a
new period of monetary plurality where
we will be
having to negotiate many many different
forms of money
both in the kind of rails the systems
that power them but also like these
mediated forms that they take
um but also the kind of tokens of um oh
it's my i need to not look at the chat
okay um
so and so how do we live in a world of
plurality
how do we negotiate that plurality how
do we deal with
deprecated money forms um
i underline the sentences you say their
plurality could mean your transactional
life is variegated
omnivorous constantly shifting between
different monies different communities
yeah yes and i think learning to live
with
plurality will be the kind of
key political question of our kind of
monetary lives
in the next in the coming decades yeah
so we have two very thoughtful questions
in the q a
um do you guys have time to stay past 6
30 or do you
need let's do can we um so i should
probably go
um for family reasons but maybe
if you can just read the two questions
and um
you know we can say like five more
minutes but if anybody needs to go
please don't i won't
you know bye thank you so much for
coming yeah
uh thank you i i have to disappear right
at 6 30 but um the questions
one is from radu it's when studying
money i tend to go to the heavy
emergence of microtransactions and video
games
how can we think of this the same way we
regard dollars in society
as a way of getting us a product or a
good or are they a commodity in
themselves
so that's one microcontract second
question thanks for a great talk sorry
for the long question
in exploring money as media i was
wondering about your take on the
similarities of oppressive economic
sanctions
impacting citizens of certain countries
denying them the use of global financial
system
and the new global social media
excluding and de-platforming certain
people and views
this idea of legitimized exclusion on
the international scale
targeting millions of citizens denying
them access to the increasingly
centralized forms of transaction
whether it's money or knowledge and of
course for access to knowledge one needs
to engage in financial transactions as
well
i think i mean that's those are both
super interesting really astute
questions and i think they really speak
to like the heart of what i'm trying to
um argue in the book which is like um
especially this idea of legitimized
exclusion
um and you know d platforming via access
to money um
and many you know financial systems um
kind of speaks this idea of like not
uh the not having access to money or
to be able to pay and be paid is as good
as like not having money at all
um and so like really really
developing a political imagination
around the rails of money rather than
just
around the um the the economic
distribution of money is really
important and to kind of speak to the um
diego's question you know that's where
we come in like we don't need to be
economists
we need to study the things that we
study with the tools that we have
because we have um really important
things to say an economist
would never think about um
the way that um it you know it's not
simply
the sanctions themselves via you know
economic relationships it's the way that
sanctions are enacted via um
you know paypal visa mastercard
and like banks um that that do
the work of transactional communication
via
what we call media systems via what we
call technology
systems um so like look for that like
look for how our our um we have the
ability to ask
questions that are being um obfuscated
or simply treated as like
um like treated as as the
as something lesser than the big picture
but reality like that's kind of where
the the inaction of these policies
actually live and what that looks like
um so yes absolutely i think and i think
that that's really complex and we need
to like spend a lot more time
thinking more about it um and similarly
i mean i think we could say you know
that microtransactions and video games
are actually quite similar
you know like what are the um you know
what are the ways that
that new monies are designed as
products and the kind of like both the
rails
of them that transmit them around the
information systems that
um allow them to exist and then like
what are the kind of political economies
of money themselves so if we can use
something like microtransactions
to inquire after the political economy
of a new money form
we can develop an apparatus that allows
us to apply that to
um you know to living with global money
plurality as it relates um
to you know economic sanctions in the
way that they're deployed via particular
infrastructures
um so yeah um
i think oddly enough those are two
questions that kind of hung together
i guess okay yeah and you were brilliant
in sort of
wrapping up that that uh that well so
yeah but i mean i will the final thing
i'll say about writing this book is that
it's kind of like a first book on a
topic and that you have
as economics economists would say like a
first mover advantage
um but there's so much more work to be
done um and kind of like
opening it up for more conversation
is like a huge part of what i hope the
work of the book is
lots of unanswered questions thanks so
much uh
thank you yes thank you all thank you
aswan
yeah thank you so much this is so
wonderful to have you both back
yeah it was really fun hopefully in
person sometime soon
yeah and i hope this format was um you
know
was uh interesting for you guys so
all right take care everybody bye